welcome to this video playing mno from
the US and down let's play some good
found reversed this is in fact a quite
nice opening for white like a some black
young must be cautious to to keep the
center let's see Knight c3 and thus t4 I
know it's not so great my can also go
Bishop g5 one rupee I don't know more
than one interesting line to play Knight
c3 here maybe ok I'll first first let's
increase the pressure
yeah some code to play with the look
before him well a seven hangs
hmm should I play be three I don't
really know protecting the pawn looks a
bit passive especially in connection
with a without fee and shadowing still
before hmm yeah I'm not sure I don't
yeah i mean the position is just very
technical I'm going for that one thing
that I'm not really sure what about
would be to now rupee too if I go Bishop
f6 Bishop f6 Luke takes d5 I'm pinning
the bishop on on the C file yeah and it
looked like quite a good position he
just he just didn't take maybe tried to
use my my slightly offside queen if I go
be three now hmm i don't want that for
you if it takes now i have night see
forms getting active play I one can take
it to it can maybe just take it to no no
no no vision of one
I don't understand any of that here I
just have bishop everyone on the ship f3
hmm
Bishop f3 I don't really see a move
against that or some lucky stuff taking
taking one on f 2 1 what what what's
kind of I don't adults don't understand
the rook moves I'll take a five and it
all falls apart
it's a ton ton of pins after 95 is the D
file we should have six threatening
after Luke c2 they don't really see what
he what you should do Bishop g4 I can
just take it is heaven as hanging at the
end
don't see move 1 p-3 p3 I will just take
yeah this is about the only only
possible move I wonder about 97 no
bishop f6 Queen f6 it's not really
working it looks some very very shaky
this position come on yes there's a win
here i'm pretty sure Knight takes this
is not working
okay I need to play a move maybe not the
most forceful one down to 119 it would
really hurt to lose this game I mean can
you can happen i mean it's it's very
messy
hard to believe all this yeah but the
game just continues I'm not winning any
material
yeah 95 a black is even better here yeah
I just let I just let one or more
opportunities slip and let him back it
back into this game
it seemed I hope that I'm not
miscalculating here with very little
time do you before is also hanging yeah
yeah 3x ah come on it just ah quite
resigned yeah ja it's Christmas for this
guy bit late but it's just like
Christmas yeah this is just okay the
funny thing is the computer gifts this
is ok for black all the way the ant is
playing playing just just good moves
96mm 96 is really better yeah well this
I saw this but I didn't didn't know what
to do yeah yeah 50 seconds and here I
just I just miscalculated I just
miscalculated this is still ok but the
weird thing is I mean it really looked
like completely unplayable for black why
isn't why isn't white better here this
is really strange
just a very good groom fraud be three
mmm Jeb don't want to play be 30 this is
just that just utterly crazy that black
is not not downright just losing here
because it's it's all hanging by a
thread to the D file and a turn here
destiny no tactic is working this is
really great like Queen d7 for example
97 Bishop p895 with check it's not
working this you can just take here yeah
27 2597 between f3 with me to come
everything is working like clockwork
yeah auntie em strangely enough there's
nothing too spectacular for white well
this is just better of course than what
I played hide I didn't see that move but
even that the computer is just giving
white 0.3 which is really disappointing
strange really strange and with very
very tough to find moves here the best
move seems to be Luke see one rook takes
Queen B 5 I always going to play that
besides a computer they don't really
understand what's so great about it
Bishop 87 for example now take take here
John i'll probably get this back some at
some point yeah very complicated as
seems like I really ever estimated my my
position here
this looks really like crap for black
okay methods if it's technically working
it's working alright thanks for watching